tenemos el honor de presentarles a su
excelencia Vladimir selenski presidente
de Ucrania
Muchas gracias
muchas muchas gracias
de verdad muchas gracias
Gracias esto es demasiado para mí
todo esto
por nuestra gran nación en nombre de
nuestra granación de verdad muchas
gracias
los estadounidenses
en todos los estados ciudades y
comunidades
todos aquellos que valoran la libertad
de la justicia
que aprecian
tan fuertemente como nosotros en
nuestras ciudades en cada familia
Espero que mis palabras de respeto y de
gratitud resuenen en cada corazón
estadounidense
señora vicepresidenta
les agradezco por sus grandes esfuerzos
para ayudar a Ucrania
señora presidenta de la cámara
usted valientemente visitó Ucrania
durante la Guerra la guerra total de
verdad muchas gracias ha sido un gran
honor
[Aplausos]
un gran privilegio para mí estar acá
queridos miembros del Congreso
representantes de ambos partidos que
también visitaron a
congresistas estimados senadores de
ambos partidos
que visitarán Ucrania Estoy seguro que
lo harán en el futuro queridos
representantes de la diáspora
[Aplausos]
miembros de la cámara personas en todo
el país queridos periodistas es un gran
honor para mí
estar en el congreso de Estados Unidos y
hablarle usted hablarles a ustedes a
todos los estadounidenses
en contra de toda posibilidad
a pesar de todo el dolor
Ucrania no cayó
Ucrania está viva
y está pateando
Thank you gracias
[Aplausos]
y me da una gran razón para compartir
con ustedes
nuestra primera Victoria conjunta
vencimos a Rusia en la batalla
no tenemos ningún miedo
nadie debería temer
Ucrania ganó esta Victoria nos da el
coraje
que inspira a todo el mundo
estadounidenses obtengan esta Victoria
obtuvieron esta Victoria por eso es que
han tenido éxito a la hora de unir a la
comunidad global para proteger al lado
libertad al Estado de derecho
internacional
los europeos ganaron esta Victoria por
eso es que Europa ahora es más fuerte y
es más independiente que nunca antes
la tiranía rusa
ha perdido su control sobre nosotros
[Aplausos]
y nunca influenciará nuestras Mentes de
nuevo aún así tenemos que hacer lo que
sea necesario para asegurarnos que los
países del sur global obtengan la misma
Victoria yo sé
que hay una cosa mucho más importante
muy importante que los rusos
tengan una posibilidad de ser libre
solamente cuando ellos venzan al kremlin
en sus propias mentes
[Aplausos]
sin embargo la batalla continúa y
tenemos que vencer al kremlin en el
campo de batalla y Sí estas batallas no
son solamente por el territorio
por esa parte de Europa otras partes de
Europa no es solamente por la vida por
la libertad y la seguridad de Ucrania o
de cualquier otra nación que Rusia
intente conquistar
esta lucha definirá En qué mundo
crecerán nuestros hijos y nietos
y luego sus hijos y sus nietos definirá
si será una democracia para los
ucranianos para los estadounidenses y
para todos
esta batalla no puede quedar congelada o
no puede no puede posponerse no puede
ser ignorada con la esperanza de que el
océano o algo más
provee algún tipo de protección
de los Estados Unidos a China de Europa
a latinoamérica de África Australia el
mundo
está demasiado interconectado es muy
interdependiente para permitir a alguien
que dé un paso al y a la vez sentirse
seguro cuando una batalla como ésta
continuó nuestras dos naciones
son aliadas en esta batalla
y el próximo año será un punto de
quiebre yo lo sé será el punto en el que
en el coraje estadounidense y la
determinación están ucraniana
definen el futuro nuestra libertad común
la libertad de las personas que defiende
sus valores
y caballeros
damas y caballeros estadounidenses ayer
antes de venir aquí
a Washington DC
estaba en la línea del frente
en nuestra ciudad de
en este fuerte al este de Ucrania en el
donbas
el ejército Ruso
y Los mercenarios
han estado atacando sin ningún tipo de
mayo día y noches Sin embargo sigue de
pie
el año pasado
el año pasado 70.000 personas vivían en
esta ciudad y ahora solamente unos pocos
civiles permanecen cada pulgada De su
tierra está humedecida
en sangre las armas suenan cada hora las
trincheras en el donbas cambian de poder
de Posesión en la mañana y en la noche
la lucha sigue Pero el doma sucraniano
sigue de pie
los rusos
han usado de todo
todo lo que tenían en contra de bakmut
en contra de otras de nuestras hermosas
ciudades
los ocupantes tienen tenían una ventaja
significativa en artillería tienen una
gran ventaja en munición tienen muchas
más misiles y muchos más aviones
que nosotros Nunca tuvimos esto es
totalmente cierto pero nuestra defensa
nuestras fuerzas defensivas están de pie
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y todos estamos orgullosos de ellos
la táctica de los rusos es primitiva
que destruyen todo lo que vengan
maleantes a las líneas de frente envían
convictos a la guerra
ellos pidan todo tipo de cosas similares
a la tiranía similar a la de la batalla
del bulbo
todo el mundo libre lo ha visto
como los soldados estadounidenses que
mantuvieron la línea y lucharon contra
las fuerzas de Hitler durante las
navidades de 1944 los Soldados
ucranianos valientes están haciendo lo
mismo contra las fuerzas de Putin esta
Navidad
Ucrania
lucrania sostiene sus líneas y nunca se
rendirá
entonces aquí en la línea de frente La
tiranía
que no carece de crueldad
ataca la vida de la gente libre su
respaldo es crucial no solamente
para mantenerse de pie en esa lucha sino
para llegar al punto de quiebre para
ganar en el campo de batalla tenemos
artillería Sí gracias
la tenemos es suficiente honestamente no
no realmente
para asegurarnos
de que no sea solamente ese fuerte que
detenga a las fuerzas rusas sino
para que las fuerzas rusas
se vayan necesitamos más cañones y más
armas es lo mismo que la batalla de
Saratoga la lucha por batmut cambiará la
trayectoria de nuestra guerra por la
independencia y por la libertad
si sus patreons
detienen el terror humano el terror ruso
contra nuestras ciudades
haremos que trabajen todo el tiempo para
defender nuestra libertad
cuando Rusia
cuando Rusia llega a nuestras ciudades
trata de destruirla con misiles
más que eso Rusia encontró un Aliado
en este política genocida Irán
los drones mortales iraníes mandados a
Rusia por los cientos se han convertido
en una amenaza contra nuestra estructura
crítica
Así es como un terrorista encontraba al
otro
es solamente un tema cuestión de tiempo
para que ataquen a otros de sus aliados
Si no los detienen ahora y tenemos que
hacerlo
yo creo
que no debería haber ningún tabú entre
nosotros y nuestra Alianza Ucrania nunca
pidió a los soldados estadounidenses que
combatieran en nuestro territorio en vez
de nosotros yo les aseguro que los
soldados ucranianos pueden operar
perfectamente tanques estadounidenses y
aviones ellos mismos
[Aplausos]
la asistencia financiera también es de
Gran importancia y quiero agradecerles a
ustedes darles Muchas gracias
por los paquetes financieros que ya nos
han brindado
y aquellos que estarían dispuestos a
decidir su dinero no es caridad
es una inversión en la seguridad global
y la democracia
que manejaremos de la manera más
responsable
[Aplausos]
Rusia podría detener su agresión
Realmente
si quisieran hacerlo pero ustedes pueden
acelerar nuestra Victoria yo lo sé
y esto demostrará a cualquier agresor
potencial que nadie puede tener éxito
destruyendo fronteras nacionales nadie
que cometa atrocidades
que maneja nuestro pueblo en contra de
su voluntad sería inocente esperar pasos
hacia la paz por parte de Rusia
que es un estado terrorista los rusos
Todavía están envenenados por parte de
la perturbación de el orden
internacional es su tarea necesitamos
Paz Ucrania ya ofrecido propuestas
que fueron discutidas con el presidente
biden nuestra fórmula de paz son diez
puntos que deben ser implementados para
obtener seguridad conjunta garantizada
de aquí a décadas en adelante una Cumbre
que puede se reunía y me alegra
afirmar que el presidente va a ir en
soporto nuestra iniciativa de paz cada
uno de ustedes damas y caballeros puede
asistir en la implementación para
asegurarse de que el liderazgo
estadounidense permanezca sólido
y bipartidista muchas gracias
ustedes pueden fortalecer sanciones para
hacer que Rusia entienda lo ruinosa que
es su agresión
está en poder de ustedes realmente
ayudarnos a traer la justicia a
cualquiera que inició esta guerra no
provocada y Criminal hagámoslo
letteries
que los terroristas
[Aplausos]
que los terroristas sean responsables
por este terror y por esta agresión y
que compensen todas las pérdidas hechas
por esta guerra que el mundo pueda ver
que los Estados Unidos están ahí
damas y caballeros
[Aplausos]
damas y caballeros estadounidenses en
dos días
celebraremos la Navidad
de pronto iluminados con velas no porque
sea más romántico sino porque no habrá
no habrá electricidad
millones No tendrán ni calefacción ni
agua
todo eso será el resultado de los
misiles rusos y de los ataques de drones
sobre nuestra infraestructura energética
pero no nos estamos quejando
no estamos juzgando no estamos
comparando
cuál vida es más fácil
su bienestar
y es el producto de su seguridad
nacional el resultado de sus luchas por
la independencia
y sus muchas victorias nosotros los
ucranianos también pasaremos por nuestra
guerra de Independencia y de libertad
con dignidad y con éxito
[Aplausos]
nosotros celebraremos la Navidad
celebraremos Navidad e incluso si no hay
ninguna electricidad
la luz de nuestra fe la luz en la fe en
nosotros no será
distinguida
si los misiles rusos nos atacan haremos
lo mejor que podamos para protegernos
y nuestro pueblo debe ir a refugios anti
bombas en Navidad Los ucranianos se
sentarán en la mesa y compartirán entre
los entre ellos
y no tenemos que saber el deseo de todos
porque sabemos que todos millones de
ucranianos deseamos lo mismo la victoria
solamente la victoria
[Aplausos]
ya hemos construido en Ucrania fuerte
con un pueblo fuerte Una institución es
fuertes ejército fuerte junto a ustedes
hemos desarrollado garantías para
nuestro país para toda Europa para todo
el mundo
junto a ustedes y también junto a
ustedes
pondremos en
su lugar
a cualquiera que desafíe la libertad
Esa será la base para proteger a la
democracia en Europa
y el mundo ahora
en este momento tan especial de Navidad
quiero agradecerles a ustedes a todos
ustedes
le agradezco a cada familia
estadounidense
que
valora y aprecia el calor de su hogar y
desea el mismo calor a otras personas le
agradezco al presidente biden y ambos
partidos al senado a la cámara
por su ayuda incesante
le agradezco a sus ciudades y a sus
ciudadanos que respaldaron a Ucrania
este año que alojaron a nuestros
ucranianos a nuestro pueblo
que ondearon nuestra bandera nacional
que reaccionaron para ayudarnos muchas
muchas gracias a todos de parte de
cualquiera de todos que están en la
línea de frente de parte de todos
que está esperando por la victoria
aquí frente ustedes Hoy recuerdo las
palabras del presidente Franklin relano
y creo que son muy buenas para este
momento
pueblo estadounidense
en su
vivir correcto vencerá sobre me seré
llegará a la victoria absoluta el pueblo
ucraniano ganará también absolutamente
[Aplausos]
de nosotros de las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas Pero hay tanto que depende
del resto del mundo hay tanto
del mundo depende de ustedes
Cuando estaba en bacmut ayer
nuestros Héroes me dieron una bandera
una bandera del campo de batalla
la bandera de aquellos que defendieron
Ucrania Europa y el mundo al costo de
sus propias vidas ellos me pidieron que
trajera esta bandera y que se las
presentara al congreso de Estados Unidos
a los miembros de la cámara de
representantes a los senadores cuyas
decisiones pueden salvar millones de
personas
así que
hagamos que estas decisiones sean Stay
with you que esta bandera se quede con
ustedes damas y caballeros esta bandera
es el símbolo de nuestra Victoria en
esta guerra nosotros estamos de pie
estamos luchando y ganaremos porque
estamos Unidos Ucrania Estados Unidos
y todo el mundo libre
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hay una cosa más
si pudiese decir lo último muchas
gracias Que Dios proteja a nuestras
valientes tropas y a nuestros ciudadanos
que por siempre Dios bendiga bendiga a
los Estados Unidos de América Feliz
Navidad
un feliz nuevo año victorioso Gloria
Ucrania